the wall
we go swimming
side by side to the end five-year-old
Shauna Flanagan garway and her father
Robert the youngest victim of the
explosion had been buying a birthday
cake for her mom
he died in her dad's arms
a truly wonderful girl who left a
lasting impression on all she met
she loved her style she was a girl with
beautiful shiny shoes and fantastic
coats
this isolated part of Ireland has had 10
funerals in the space of five days two
teenagers who attended the same College
were among the dead Ireland's president
has spent much of the week here in a
small community where the relationships
are so close and where people have
intimate knowledge of families and
circumstances it isn't a single person
or a family that carries the big lash of
Eternal tragedy like this but it is the
whole community
The Village fell silent at 3 20 on
Friday afternoon exactly a week after
the suspected gas explosion at this
filling station
their painful awareness of the fragility
of Life having been articulated by a 12
year old who received a standing ovation
at his father's funeral
I'd like to say that we should be
grateful
for your families cherish them be
grateful because they won't be there
forever so use up the time you have
wisely
also be grateful for your life because
that two will not last forever but be
grateful for you will be able to rest
after your hard work thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
they've buried their dad but life will
never be the same here 10 lives taken in
a village of just 400 people this corner
of Ireland known for its beauty forever
scarred by unimaginable loss
David belevin's Sky News at crease lock
in County Donegal